hallo ich habe heute einen vortrag zu
meinem kaninchen mitgebracht aber uli
meinte ich soll schon wieder über die
afg reden kann ich nicht doch über mein
kaninchen reden nein
okay das ist mein kaninchen mein
kaninchen ist sehr süß ich habe mal die
süßen teile markiert das ist hier hier
und hier sich aber eigentlich ist es
überall süß mein kaninchen ist im
prinzip das genaue gegenteil der afd
es ist jung flauschig und vor allem
nicht rassistisch drei zu null für mein
kaninchen
natürlich ist auch die afd
nicht nur das ist durch schnell man
muster differenzieren es gibt in der afg
grob gesehen zwei gruppen zum einen die
rassisten
zum andern die dies okay finden mit
rassisten in der gleichen partei zu sein
das sind das sind die toleranten in der
afc
es gibt ein lacher naja nächste runde
mein kaninchen ist ein fluchttier
genauso wie das gesamte spitzenpersonal
der fdp ti ist bereits aus der eigenen
partei geflohen
auch bauland ist als junger mensch aus
der ddr in die bundesrepublik geflohen
quasi als wirtschaftsflüchtling
röcke ist aus westdeutschland nach
ostdeutschland geflohen weil er sich
dort ein besseres leben für sich selbst
versprochen hat aus dem gleichen motiv
ist heute nach brüssel ins
europaparlament geflohen und weil hat
die längste flucht hinter sich sie ist
aus der realität in die afg geworden
wir sehen hier nur angsthasen es ist
unentschieden vier zu eins so mein
kaninchen frist seine eigene scheiße die
asd nicht klarer punkt für die afg 42
man muss aber auch sagen dass es einige
gemeinsamkeiten gibt zwischen kaninchen
und der afd
kaninchen haben zum beispiel sehr harte
kämpfe zur rangfolge sie sind extrem
revier bezogen und alle konflikte werden
gnadenlos ausgetragen also hier auch ein
unentschieden 5 zu 3 und dann zum
letzten vergleich die afg hat überhaupt
keinen mut zur wahrheit sie behauptet zb
ständig wir sind keine rechtsextreme
da ist das kaninchen ehrlicher und sagt
ich bin süßes kaninchen klarer klarer
punkt
klara punkt für das kaninchen das ist
dann auch der endsieg weiß ich nicht
jedenfalls das kaninchen hat
überraschend klar gewonnen und ich habe
neulich ein video auf facebook
veröffentlicht zum thema rassismus
daraufhin habe ich folgenden kommentar
bekommen und ich muss hier hinzufügen
ich habe keine rechtschreibfehler dazu
gedichtet die sind original stand dann
du klingst wiegen drogenopfer und da
dachte ich dann ja gut dagegen kann ich
nichts sagen und ich als nicht nach sie
sage dir da dachte ich so schlimm kann's
nicht werden halt die fresse und
gestorben
aber drei smileys da war ich erleichtert
micro sim slot meine damen und herren
[Applaus]